[Music]
Michelle was this great she was a
wonderful Talent you guys had a had a
kiss yes years ago yes do you do you it
was an interracial kiss of course it
wasn't anything at the time but uh but a
beautiful woman and uh and a friend and
and my kids enthusiastically Michelle
passed away in July but it's the death
of fellow Star Trek Star Leonard Nimoy
that still haunts Shatner to this day
you guys had a challenge relationship
you mentioned in the in the fun only at
the end I don't know what happened it
just uh he wouldn't answer my calls I
wrote him a heartfelt letter
uh saying how much I loved him and I
wished him well because he was dying and
I wanted to see him and and I was so
so I am
so
hurt so devastated his daughter reached
out to you she said you know he loved
you so somebody said you know they've
known people who got ill and didn't want
to see anybody because they were ill and
I'd like to say that that was that was
the reason
at 91 years young William is still in
great health last year he famously went
into orbit on Blue origin a trip his
family tried to talk him out of I'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened don't go don't go everybody
doesn't really don't go you're gonna die
when they say that they know that I
don't know inside Bill's office special
mementos and awards line the walls all
capturing memories of his 70-year career
and in his new book boldly go out today
he shares personal stories about his
co-stars and His Four marriages I want
to talk your marriages and divorces when
I got married it was forever I was
deeply in love they were my best friend
the marriages that I have been in were
for great lengths of time yeah 12 years
22 years 17 years what happens
to people everybody is you grow
a lot of people myself included
grew apart and so
the choices do you stay forever or do
you say that's a part of my life
our life that's over let's try and try
again
[Music]
thank you
foreign